there were many
stories linking you to lebron linking
you to the lakers
uh then i saw something link you to the
clippers and ultimately
you know i had said in my mind like
there's a high possibility you know you
you may want to go back home
uh
most importantly just to be close to
moms obviously
uh with
pops passing away which you know
again sorry for the loss i know that's
tough i can't imagine um
ultimately you decided to go
to chicago why did you end up saying all
right you know what i'm not doing that
was it
those two teams didn't have the right
amount of money was it you just saw an
opportunity in chicago what was yeah i
mean it was it was a real possibility um
i mean i'd be lying to you if i didn't
say i wanted to come home you know
i did try to make it happen there's a
real possibility on it happening um you
know just things didn't work out you
know what i mean but
you know um
chicago was always
in my top five that was always on my
radar you know what i mean
he made the move to get lonzo
great pickup
been a fan of his and and
you see the narrative changed with zach
wanted to stay if i came and
obviously bush there and
you know we just built off that to where
it's like all right this thing be really
be a possibility then on the back end of
it it's a hell of a city
hell of a city absolutely hell of an
organization to where like you get this
thing winning here
it's
it's come on